MALE SPEAKER: This
is Jeremy Frank.
He's going to [INAUDIBLE].
It's turns out he went to
school with Laszlo Bock.
JEREMY FRANK: Almost.
MALE SPEAKER: Almost.
You were off by a couple years,
at Pomona College,
which I think is
kind of funny.
So you send things to space.
He sends his Googlers
into work.
So, yeah.
So I don't want to waste
too much time.
But I wanted to draw attention
to his shirt.
He used to work for Yoyodyne
Propulsion Systems, which is a
small company in [INAUDIBLE],
right?
Where they made an advance B-1
bomber subsystem for the
defense department before
they were shut down.
JEREMY FRANK: Yeah.
I can neither confirm nor deny
that aliens were involved.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So you worked for
John something.
Well, anyway the long and short
of it is I don't waste
any more time.
So please [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY FRANK: That's plausible.
OK.
So thank you very much.
So I wanted to talk to you today
about some work that
NASA is doing to figure out
how to send people to far
distant planets, possibly
Mars, but possibly other
things that are not quite
planet-like, near-Earth asteroids.
So what I want to do is tell
you a little bit about what
some of those destinations are,
and how far away they
are, and in particular how long
it would take to talk to
a crew of astronauts who might
be at those destinations.
And the reason I want to talk
about this is because when we
think about how space missions
are operated today, in
particular human space mission
operations, time delay is
going to be a real problem.
But to give you a sense of what
all that means, I need to
tell you a little about
operations.
And in particular, some of the
things that can go wrong
during operations and why it's
really important to think
about those things, especially
in the presence of these large
time delays.
And what this really boils
down to is a matter of
communication.
So the communication between the
spacecraft and the flight
control team, what happens
during that communication, why
people need to communicate, and
why this is going to be a
little bit different if
we do these things
tomorrow, than it is today.
And after I do that, I can
tell you about some
experiments that NASA has done
in order to really try and
quantify the impact of time
delay on mission operations,
explain how we try and quantify
what can go wrong,
what things are going
to go right.
And we have some technologies
that we've been investigating,
some things that you are very
familiar with and some things
that you may not be so familiar
with it, that we
think are going to actually
mitigate the
impact of time delay.
And so I want to describe this
experiment that we did and
tell you what we learned.
And I have a flow of this
presentation, but please feel
free to interrupt with questions
at any time.
I should also warn you there
are some audience
participation questions.
So be prepared.
I will be calling for people
to help me out here in the
middle of my talk.
So without further delay, that
is a picture of Apollo 11 on
the lunar surface.
Are you surprised at the
color of the dirt?
Because the Moon's
gray, right?
Well, no.
It turns out not all
the Moon is gray.
Sometimes it looks a little
reddish-orange.
But more interestingly to us for
this talk, the Moon is a
paltry 238,000 miles
away from Earth.
So light travels from
the Earth to the
Moon in only 1.2 seconds.
Well, so in a day and age of
instant communication, 1.2
seconds may seem like
a long time.
But really from the point of
view of mission operations,
that's not so bad.
So we've done that.
We've experienced that before.
But there are some places that
are interesting that NASA
would like to potentially send
people that are a little bit
further away.
One thing that you may have
been hearing a little bit
about in the news recently
is asteroids.
Certain classes of asteroids
have been
termed near-Earth asteroids.
So what is a near-Earth
asteroid?
So this is one.
This asteroid is called
1998 QE2.
What a great sexy name.
But what should be slightly more
interesting perhaps is
that in May of this year, this
asteroid passed a paltry 3.6
million miles from the Earth.
Well, OK, so 3.6 million
miles, that
sounds like a long time.
It's 14 light seconds
from Earth.
So it's actually quite a bit
further away from the Moon.
It's not the closest thing that
has passed to the Earth
and there are some others
that are further away.
But the point is these are
things that are very, very
interesting.
They're very old.
They're very scientifically
interesting.
There's a lot of very, very cool
exploration science that
people want to do.
Some of that science we think
we want to do by sending
people there.
And so the question
is where are they?
How far away are they?
Well, so here's a
close-ish one.
And here's a slightly more
interesting one.
So this one's interesting
because if you take a look at
it, you see these kind of smooth
surfaces and all this
bumpy stuff.
So your picture of asteroids
may be a great big,
solid hunk of rock.
Well, not all of them
are like that.
Something like this may resemble
more like a great big
pile of dirt in space, loosely
held together.
So how many of them
are like that?
Well, we don't really know.
This one's a little bit
far away though.
It is 26 million miles,
2.3 minute light
time delay to Earth.
So that one's pretty far away.
And yet, there are some
asteroids like that that we're
considering sending people to.
So pretty far away, yes.
And then, of course
there's Mars.
So for those of you who
don't necessarily
recognize this picture.
This is Mount Sharp.
This is the shadow
of Curiosity.
Ooh, the shadow of Curiosity
is a little bit more shaded
than I thought it would be.
And so everybody knows how
far away Mars is, right?
Anybody know?
No.
When Mars is close to Earth,
it's 35 million miles.
Light takes three minutes to
get to Mars from Earth.
Three minutes, that's
when it's close?
What about when it's far away?
Well, when it's far away, it's
pretty far, 250 million miles,
24 minutes one way.
So these numbers should give you
some pause when we think
casually about sending people
to these places.
And that's the whole point.
So these are a range
of places NASA's
considered sending people.
So when we talk about
spaceflight mission
operations, future human
destinations, this is the
range of places that people are
interested in, the kinds
of things that we would
like to do.
So what does it take today to
actually operate a human space
flight mission?
What do people do?
Well, they sit at these
banks of computers,
many, many of them.
Each one of them has a job.
And that job is to keep
their crew and
their spacecraft safe.
That's primarily what they do.
But what does that
actually mean?
So to an astronaut, mission
control is the power company.
They're the plumber.
They're the air conditioner
repairman.
They are the doctor.
They're the phone company.
They're geek squad.
They're everything
to those people.
Because any time anything goes
wrong on their spacecraft, any
time the crew needs help doing
something on board their
spacecraft, if they have a
problem, these are the people
who they have to call.
Very much like we do, only it's
not like you can drive to
the doctor's office.
It's not like you can get UPS
to deliver you a new hard
drive for your computer.
You pretty much have to take
care of it yourself, with the
help of those people on the
other end of the phone.
So far so good?
So the people who sit in the
mission control center who
assist the astronauts in doing
all of this work, they have a
large profusion of different
kinds of tools that they use
in order to help operate
that spacecraft.
So what I want to do is show
you a couple of those tools
and talk a little bit
about what they do.
So one thing that they do, for
example, this is a set of what
are called displays for, in this
case, it's a little hard
to read, but you might be able
to see that this is ECLSS,
Environmental Control and
Life Support Systems.
So if you're a flight
controller who's
responsibility is ECLSS, you
care about what the atmosphere
inside the spacecraft
is composed of.
Is it to hot?
Is it to warm?
Is it too cold?
Does it have the right
gas composition?
Is there CO2 collecting any
place inside your spacecraft,
which could be very dangerous
for your astronauts?
But that's what you're doing.
So you have these displays which
are basically watching
data which is coming from the
spacecraft and telling you
whether things are doing
what they are
supposed to do or not.
So there are a variety of these
tools and their whole
purpose in life is to give
those flight controllers
insight into the spacecraft.
So here's another one.
So instead of just getting the
numbers and watching those
numbers updating.
You might need to see
plots for trends.
So it's a different view of
the same class of data.
So another thing that you might
need to do as a flight
controller is you might actually
need to tell your
vehicle to do something.
So you might need to say, turn
a piece of equipment on, turn
a piece of equipment
off, gather
information about things.
So what you now have is you
have a set of commanding
displays, very similar to
your data displays.
But instead of being used for
monitoring your vehicle, these
are used to command
your vehicle.
So a slightly different
form of a tool.
Sometimes you don't want
to send one command.
You may need to send a large
number of commands.
And if you do this enough times,
you may want to write a
simple script or essentially a
program in order to send that
sequence of commands and
just watch it go.
So in addition to single
commanding tools, you may have
some sort of script execution
monitoring tools like this.
So similar in spirit to sending
a set of commands is
the idea of a procedure.
So a step by step set of
instructions that someone,
either a flight controller or a
crew person, is going to use
in order to accomplish
some task.
So in addition to just the set
of commands, you may need some
explanatory text.
You may have some sort of flow
control boxes, something a
little bit like a flow chart
that helps you understand what
it is that you're doing, what
tools you need, what pieces of
information are supposed to say
what in order for you to
go to the next step.
So these procedures are very,
very standardized and
regularized.
And so there are tools to help
you see what those procedures
say and to help you track
where they are.
So now it is strategic level,
procedure steps are things to
take tens of seconds to maybe
a minute to execute.
At a much more strategic level,
on the course of a day,
you have tools that help
you understand what
your daily plan is.
So in this case, we see a
plan for a subset of the
International Space Station
astronauts over the course of
a couple of hours.
You're seeing information like
is it day or night apparently,
because of where the
spacecraft is
relative to the Sun.
You're seeing what kind
of communication
coverage you have.
You're seeing things like what's
happening with respect
to communication coverage
on the ground.
Is the ground tracking
activities
that the crew is doing?
And so you have an information
display like this that's sort
of showing you what
your plans are.
So who has lost something
in your house?
You don't know where it is.
It's in the garage.
It's in the closet.
And it's really important
because you need it.
Because you're going to the
beach and your kids are
yelling at you because you
can't find the sand toys.
OK, so astronauts don't
have sand toys.
But similarly, a lot of the
activities that they do
require something, say
batteries, a pair of scissors,
a piece of tubing.
And this is somewhere
in your space craft.
Well, where is it?
So in addition to all of these
activities and procedures, you
may have information that's
basically logistics, stowage,
and tracking.
So that you can efficiently go
find those pieces of equipment
that you actually need in order
to do whatever you need
to do on your day.
So this is also very
important.
So as an aside, any web
developers in the audience?
Since the year 2000, the
International Space Station
has flown a variety of tools
based on web technology that
help them do all of
these things.
And they've also been
in use in the flight
control room as well.
So from what I've been able to
gather, the first of these
tools was basically used to
monitor the state of air to
ground file transfers so
that the crew knew
what they had to do.
But since then, it's been
extended to both procedure
display and plan display
and execution tracking.
So technology you built, may
be on board ISS today.
How about that?
So a small subset of the
technology that's being used
is listed here.
OK.
So you're all experts on
operations now, right?
So let's talk a little bit
about communications.
So I think it's pretty clear
at this point that
communications is pretty
critical to both delivering
all of this information
to these tools,
as well as to people.
So voice and video communication
to the control
center is quite important.
I'm not going to
dwell on that.
It's not a big part of what I
want to talk about today.
And yet we've talked about
how time delay
can make things worse.
So here is the first of
our little audience
participation games.
So I need a volunteer.
You're my volunteer, great.
You don't need to go anywhere.
You can stay there.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to simulate
something that might happen on
board a hypothetical future
space mission with time delay.
So some blue text is going to
appear on the screen, which I
will ask you to read
when it appears.
So perhaps you've made
a phone call.
So hi, this is ACE
Air Conditioner.
How can I help you?
Well, so five seconds
after I say that--
AUDIENCE: Our A/C hasn't been
working for the last day.
JEREMY FRANK: You hear it.
And then you get to
say your piece.
And five seconds after
that, I hear it.
When was the last time
that your air
conditioner was serviced?
Oh, this is really
frustrating.
We've haven't even gotten to the
interesting stuff and its
frustrating.
AUDIENCE: When you last serviced
it three years ago.
JEREMY FRANK: I'm twiddling
my thumbs.
Oh, the tension is mounting.
Have there been any
interruptions in power?
OK, so you get the idea.
So there's one more text box.
But the point is that if you
were say on your way to QE
1998, 14 light seconds away,
you're a third the way there,
five light seconds, and the
air conditioner on your
spacecraft goes out.
And you're not entirely sure
what to do about it as an
astronaut, you might have
that very experience.
And it's just going to get worse
as you go on to Mars.
So ever since I started looking
into this time delay
business, I've been thinking
about how we communicate with
each other.
And so I have a very, very brief
and incomplete history
of how people have communicated,
not going all
the way back to the Dark Ages.
But think about if you were
alive in 1860 before the Civil
War, and you wanted to send a
message to someone, and you
had to put your message on a
stagecoach that was going
roughly in the direction of
wherever your friends lived,
back in the East coast.
It could take you weeks in order
to send a message, never
mind if you wanted to get a
message across the ocean.
So revolutions in communication
like the Pony
Express in 1861 and the
telegraph and especially the
transatlantic telegraph, this
just profoundly changed the
way that we talk
to each other.
And, of course, we've
lived through the
revolution in SMS and email.
We now have devices in our
pockets, that people could not
have imagined having in their
homes, which allow us to
pretty much communicate
anything, voice, video, text,
data, anything we want,
at an instant.
We're not tied to our
houses anymore.
So this idea of instantaneous
communication is really
something quite new.
And so to some extent, we're
going back to the past if we
think about what happens when
we send people to very, very
distant planets.
We're going to be stuck back
in the dark ages of
communication again.
And so of course the human
factors issues of texting from
the surface of the Moon again
aside, things are going to be
quite different.
So that's enough about
communications.
But really we've been operating
human spacecraft,
human-occupied spacecraft
for over 50 years now.
There have been ISS crew
people on board ISS
continuously for
over a decade.
Is there really anything
to learn?
So I want to reinforce
that space is a
dangerous place, even now.
Being in space is dangerous.
Bad things can happen on board
your spacecraft all the time.
And part of the reason why we
care about this is so that we
can respond if something
bad happens.
So almost everybody remembers
that Apollo 13 was a big
problem during the Apollo era
and that that mission was
saved by ground.
It is not widely remembered
that of the other Apollo
missions, many of them were
saved by timely intervention
from the ground when something
really bad happened.
So Apollo 11 I think is one of
the more interesting ones.
So what this 1202 alarm during
the lunar module descent was--
basically the Apollo guidance
computer on the lunar module
was overworked.
And as a result of its overwork,
it basically started
issuing these alerts messages.
And nobody but the engineers who
built it really understood
what was going on.
So the crew didn't know if they
were going to have to
abort this landing or not
until ground told them
everything's fine.
You're still safe to land.
But they didn't know.
And the others are equally
interesting and I invite you
to learn more about
them later.
But unlike in the Apollo era,
flight controllers sitting in
the control center
fly the ISS.
The astronauts are up
there to do science.
The vehicle is flown
from the ground.
So we don't even have the
experience that they had in
terms of astronauts owning
and understanding
how to fly the vehicle.
So when, for example, you have
a problem on board the
International Space Station
like a big old tear in the
solar arrays, ground has
to understand what the
implications of that and figure
out how to fix it.
When, for example, a
micrometeorite punches a hole
in a thermal panel causing it
to blow out, ground has to
understand how to reroute the
thermal control system and
keep the vehicle safe.
When, for instance-- you
won't see it here--
there is an ammonia leak in the
thermal control system,
which basically forces you to
shut down a whole power
channel because you can't keep
it cool anymore, what do you
do when your station is now
at one eighth less power?
Ground is taking care
of business.
Crew can't do that, not today.
That's why all this time delay
stuff really matters.
So hopefully I've hammered
all that home.
So as a result, we understand
that something has to change.
We can't operate the way that we
usually do in the presence
of time delay.
But what exactly can't we do?
What kind of responsibility
can we shift to the crew?
What does the ground have to do
differently in the presence
of time delay for these
future missions?
So that's really the question
that the work I'm now going to
talk about is meant to answer.
So let me pause and ask
anybody, you got any questions?
Anybody got anything they
want to know about, any
observations before we get
into the next bit?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The near-Earth
asteroids, are there any
motivations to gather resources
from an asteroid?
And can you even tell like what
kinds of resources are
available remotely?
JEREMY FRANK: Right.
Great question.
So the short answer is yes.
There are a lot of hypotheses
about what kinds of resources
could be on those asteroids.
I think the notion of heavy
metals, like gold, and iron,
and nickel, there are some
asteroids that have those.
But they tend to be very far
away, at least as far as I
understand it.
And so other kinds of
resources people are
interested in are things
like radioactives.
People think that, for
instance, there are
radioactives is on the Moon
that might be mined.
But it's very difficult to get
a good sense of what's
underneath an asteroid.
If there's something that's on
the surface, you might be able
to observe its spectra with a
telescope from the ground or a
space-based telescope.
But hard to find out
what's inside.
And I think that nobody should
get too excited about us being
able to mine asteroids
in the near term.
It's a very exciting idea.
But we can hardly even get there
in the first place, let
alone bring stuff back.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you think crew
obviously also mean the
on-board computers, which given
what you said so far,
seem to be needing to take
on a large part of the
responsibility.
JEREMY FRANK: That's right.
So we distinguish
between vehicle
automation and crew autonomy.
So things like computers taking
action and being able
to control systems, we would
tend to refer to that as
automation in some way,
shape, or form.
And you're absolutely right.
One of the things that we think
we're going to have to
do is make the computers able to
do more or different tasks
than they do today.
There are questions about how
effective that can be.
Can it be trusted?
Is it complex?
Is it too expensive?
But many of those same questions
apply to shifting
responsibility to the crew.
Nobody else?
OK.
So far, so good.
So we're NASA.
So we can do all sorts of very,
very interesting things.
So in order to answer this
question, we decided that we
were going to build ourselves
a spacecraft.
And we were going to send it
someplace really far away,
like Texas.
And we were then going to
operate it under a variety of
these conditions in order to
simulate the time delays,
simulate the kinds of activities
that we think would
happen on such mission, try and
introduce some of these
unexpected events, and produce
a set of sort of impact
assessment of what
would happen.
And then we have some of these
mitigation technologies that
people have been
thinking about.
So we wanted to experiment with
those under basically the
same experimental conditions and
see what worked and what
didn't work before we
do it for real.
So here you are.
You don't want to see that
when your on board your
spacecraft.
So I'm not entirely joking when
I said that NASA built
the spacecraft.
We didn't build it to fly
in space, unfortunately.
But the Deep Space Habitat
spacecraft test facility that
we used here was built at
Johnson Space Center.
And its whole purpose in life
was to do this class of
experiment, to basically serve
as an analog so that you could
do these kinds of operational
tests, try out a variety of
advanced technologies, in order
to see what does and
does not work for these
future missions.
And so in addition to that,
mission control in Johnson
Space Center has a similar
facility, the operations
technology facility, where
they test operations
technologies for use on future
and also on current
spacecraft.
So they kindly lent us some
space that we could use to
create a mini-control center
in order to operate
the Deep Space Hab.
And so that's our
test harness.
And so what I'm going to do now
is I'll tell you a little
bit about the sort of miniature
mission that we created.
And I'll go through its mission
timeline a little bit.
And then I'll describe the
mitigation technologies that
we used to try and see what
happened with time delay.
So what we had was a crew of
four quote, quote "astronauts"
in our spacecraft, one of whom
actually was an astronaut.
And then we had a set of flight
control positions, with
responsibilities like those
things that I described.
So we had a power systems flight
controller, thermal
systems, chief medical officer,
operations planning,
and so on and so forth.
And these people basically
conducted these simulated
two-hour mission timelines.
And here is our mission
timeline.
So what I'll do is go through
a subset of these activities
and describe what they are.
But this is the kind of thing
that you would expect to see
during a part of the mission
where there's no vehicle
docking, there's no vehicle
undocking, there's nobody
going outside on an
extravehicular activity.
People are basically staying
inside the spacecraft, living
and working, taking
care of business.
Not exactly doing the laundry,
but doing things that are sort
of regular, recurring tasks
that are, if you like,
important, but not
sort of highly
dynamic, energetic events.
And so let's walk through the
timeline and see what some of
these activities are in a
little bit more detail.
So one thing that happens
a fair amount with your
mechanical equipment on board
the spacecraft is you need to
inspect it frequently to
make sure that it's
still working properly.
This is a piece of exercise
equipment.
It's very important for the
crew exercise, to maintain
bone and muscle mass inside
zero gravity.
But all that mechanical
equipment can wear out.
You definitely don't want it
breaking while a crew person
is exercising with it.
So you conduct inspections
periodically to make sure it's
working right.
You send pictures back
to the ground.
Ground does an inspection,
makes sure everything is
working OK.
Part of the hypothesis for these
long duration missions
of the future is that perhaps
we can use plants, both as
sources of food and also
environmental control.
So we pretended that we
had plants on board.
So there's a regular soil
sampling activity to make sure
that the plants are
staying healthy.
Just like at home, if your air
conditioner filter doesn't get
replaced, your A/C doesn't
work very well.
So we had a simulated
air conditioner
filter replacement activity.
In addition, we assumed that we
were on our way back from
some planetary destination where
we collected a number of
samples, rock and
soil samples.
So there's the sample inventory
activity to make
sure that those samples'
condition and placement is
well understood.
So you remember the
micrometeorite strike on ISS?
Well, so every so often you may
need to conduct some sort
of external inspection of part
of your vehicle with a camera
that's mounted outside, that can
take pictures to make sure
that the outside of
your spacecraft
is looking all right.
And then the last one is a
fluid transfer activity.
So there are various
repositories of fluid.
It can either be fuel, sometimes
it could be water,
waste perhaps.
And so every so often, you may
need to move fluid from one
place to another.
And so that's another common
activity that people had.
So we had about a dozen
of these activities.
And we had a full timeline.
So really in that two hours,
there wasn't a whole lot of
time for anything to go wrong.
There wasn't a whole lot of time
for activities to take
longer than expected either.
And so what we wanted to do
also was to disrupt the
timeline with a variety
of unexpected events.
So we had a pretty rich power
system inside the Deep Space
Hab and we were able to
selectively fail components.
So as you'll see later, there's
power distribution,
power conversion, and a variety
of other pieces of the
power system which
we could decide
weren't working properly.
Sometimes they decided they
weren't working properly all
by themselves, which was
kind of exciting.
I'm sorry.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Were either the crew
or the simulated mission
control notified in advance
what failures
you're going to run?
JEREMY FRANK: No.
No.
There's an extensive experiment
design that I'm not
going to really get into.
But no, we wanted very much
to keep that secret.
So we had a set of people
working those failures up,
making sure that we had good,
reasonable failures that
actually could disrupt the
timeline, but we're going to
totally blow us out
of the water.
And in fact, there's lots of
good insight about that that
we can discuss a little
bit later.
So the fluid system was a
software fluid simulation.
We thought about using a
hardware simulation, decided
not to do that.
So with the software fluid-based
simulation, we do
just about anything we wanted.
So that was very good.
And we were exceedingly lucky.
We were able to work with some
people at Johnson Space Center
in space medicine, both
certified ultrasound
technicians and also some
very, very cool medical
autonomous operations
technology.
So they partnered with us.
And we were able to do crew
medical emergencies, in which
case either urinary retention
or kidney stone actually
present with very similar
symptoms and both of them are
diagnosed using ultrasounds.
And so that was a great
ambiguous crew down, medical
emergency situation.
We were able to perform
the ultrasound.
We weren't able to do anything
after the ultrasound.
But even that was pretty cool.
Some of our flight controllers
got to do ultrasounds for the
first time.
That was pretty exciting.
So that gives us a pretty
interesting set of things that
we can introduce in order
to disrupt our timeline.
So here we are.
Here's our poor, hapless flight
controller doing his
ultrasound.
OK.
So we had four distinct crews.
And it was very important to us
to have distinct crews so
that basically crews couldn't
sort of gain experience in the
experiment design.
And that was really
tremendous.
We got volunteer astronauts
in order to serve as our
commanders.
But all of our crews and flight
controllers were either
certified flight controllers
from the International Space
Station or shuttle program.
So when you hear the results of
what these experiments are
telling you, keep
this in mind.
Because these are the experts,
the people who actually do
this every single day, telling
us what did and didn't work.
And that was very, very
valuable to us.
So I'm just going to skip this
because I think I want to make
up a little bit of time here.
Oh, I'm actually doing great.
So we essentially took all of
those situations, either
nothing happens, we disrupt
things with system failures,
we disrupt them with crew
medical emergencies, these
time delays that we wanted
to experiment with.
And we said, let's pretend we
were doing basically the way
ISS is operated today, see what
happens, try and get sort
of a baseline what's the impact
of time delay under
these circumstances?
And then let's take some things
that we think are going
to make delayed operations a
little bit less painful and
compare them point by point and
see if we can get a sense
of whether things are made
better and if so how and why.
So let's talk a little bit about
what some of these are.
So you remember, we talked a
little bit our procedures, the
step by step instructions that
tell people what to do, and
where to go, and what
pieces of equipment
they're going to use.
Well, today those are mostly
electronic documents
presented as PDFs.
But if you're going to send a
command, and the procedure
tells you to send a command, you
got to go to some new tool
to send the command.
If you need to refer to a
piece of data and decide
whether to do the next step or
not, you have to go to another
tool in order to see that.
So an advanced electronic
procedure display allows you
to send commands, renders your
telemetry, and tells you
whether or not you've got a
problem with the next step.
So we see here this piece of
telemetry in this yellow box.
Well, that's telling you, if you
get to that step and that
box is still yellow, you can't
do that command yet.
You can see which procedures
are active.
You can see we've procedures
are done.
If other pieces of technology
are recommending procedures,
you see those.
You have step tracking and all
kinds of other very cool
advanced features.
So this is one thing that's sort
of a step above today's
practice in terms of operations
technology.
Both crews and flight
controllers
can make use of this.
Primarily, this was for
the crew's use in
our experiments though.
So you have the great question
about our software going to
make us smarter?
Is it going to do more?
Well, one of the things it can
do is it can tell us whether
we have a problem.
It can diagnose problems.
It can tell us what the
consequences of problems are.
It can tell us well, I know
there's a problem.
Maybe there's an ambiguity.
I can recommend something
to disambiguate
what the problem is.
So here's a somewhat hard
to see, schematic
of the power system.
But what we're seeing here is
that a 24-volt DC converter
has failed.
So that's what the solid
red box indicates.
As a consequence, all these
things that are kind of dimly
visible in this outlined red
box, those are components that
have been taken down as a
result of that failure.
So this is a combined schematic
of your system, with
a piece of software living
behind it that is trying to do
that advance caution and
warning, fault detection,
isolation, and recovery
technology task.
So again, this is the kind of
thing that could be available
on board if the computational
resources are available.
It could also be used inside
the flight control room.
So in addition to those things,
something a little simpler.
Why don't the astronauts chat?
Why not give them chat?
So that was a pretty
obvious one.
In fact, there should be an
experiment on board ISS with
chat now, partially driven by
what we did during this
experiment a couple years ago.
So in order to create these
mitigation technologies, we
put together a gigantic list of
components under the covers.
One of the things that I want
to draw attention to is over
here on the protocol side, not
only are these protocols for
basically moving information
around, both within our
simulated spacecraft and also
inside our simulated flight
control room, this was also
what we used in order to
simulate the time delay.
Voice, video, data, audio, all
of them were actually put into
simulated time delay loops.
And this was part of the
way that we did it.
So you can make me look dumb by
asking me questions about
this since this is not really
my expertise area.
But But this is just a
small subset of the
things that we used.
So any questions about that?
I kind of flew through it pretty
quickly, but before we
get on into what we learned?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned kind
of the advance electronic
document sort of
thing, so PDFs.
One of the side effects
of that, though--
I mean is that the only control
mechanism that someone
would have or is that in
addition to that extra tool
that you described?
JEREMY FRANK: Right.
Good question.
So even today, procedures are
always backed up by single
command displays where you can
issue individual commands.
Because no battle plan
ever survives
contact with the enemy.
No procedure survives contact
with the real situation.
So in the event that you sort of
wandered outside the bounds
of what you know how to do, you
always need another way to
command the system and
to get the insight.
So in terms of measurement,
how do we actually measure
what happened?
So there are a variety of
questionnaires that people
have developed over the years in
order to assess things like
what is a person's workload,
what is the difficulty of
communication coordination,
and things like that.
We could also take metric
measurements of things like
how often did people talk,
how long did people talk.
And those are the kinds of
things that we were able to
use in order to figure
out whether things
became harder or easier.
You might ask well, could
you count the
number of tasks performed?
Could you count the number
of procedure
steps and their delays?
We did that and we
saw no impact.
So I'm not to say anything
more about that.
But audience participation
opportunity number two.
So what do you think?
Based on this experiment, based
on what you've heard, do
you think the time delay is
going to make things harder or
easier, just curious?
Show of hands if you think
it's going to be harder.
Almost everybody thinks it's
going to be harder.
So without knowing anything
more than I've said about
these mitigation technologies,
do you think they're going to
make things better?
Show of hands if they're
going to be better.
Some people, a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Harder to identify.
JEREMY FRANK: Anybody think
it's going to be worse?
Is this going to cause damage?
Are we going to mess this up?
No, OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: What did you think?
JEREMY FRANK: Pardon?
JEREMY FRANK: We really
didn't know.
We formulated this hypothesis
that things
were going to be different.
Things did not turn out quite
the way we expected though.
We didn't really have
a good sense of what
was going to happen.
So I apologize.
There's some quantitative
data here.
We ran a total of 10 experiments
at each time delay
setting, 10 at 50, 10 at 300.
So this is what the crew members
said they thought how
workload changed with
time delay.
So the crew thought workload
was higher at
the higher time delay.
The crew thought workload went
down when we added those
mitigation technologies.
We did not expect that.
We expected something like well,
it'll increase with time
delay, but it'll be less.
We didn't expect workload
to actually decrease.
That was a surprise.
We didn't understand that.
This is more like what
we expected.
So this is what the flight
control team said.
So the flight controller said
well, time delay is making
things harder.
But the mitigations are
making things easier.
But it's making it easier
across the board.
So that was interesting.
So we got some surprises
right away.
OK, so this in words
is pretty much what
the charts are showing.
So that was interesting.
So we have statistical
significance tests.
And yeah, most of this looks
like it's actually real.
The variances are a little
bit high, but it's
actually a real effect.
So just looking at that though,
that's not quite enough.
Because that's only telling us
sort of grossly speaking what
people's experience was in
sort of metric terms.
But in addition to these sort of
numerical measurements, we
also got hem or to
answer questions.
And what they told us in words
about what did and didn't work
and why it didn't work was
really interesting.
So here's one example.
And I have a lot of these
in the charts.
And I don't know if I'm going
to go through them all.
But what are they saying?
So this second quote is
especially interesting.
To keep from falling behind,
while I was waiting for the
ground to tell me the answer
to a question, I started
something else.
So what are they doing?
They're getting ahead.
But in doing so, they're
imposing workload on
themselves to keep track
of what tasks
they're currently doing.
So they're trying
to multitask.
They're trying to do multiple
things at once.
And it's making it harder.
What else are they doing?
Oh, when they ask a question
and they're not getting an
immediate response, they're
creating work because now they
have to monitor the auditory
channel for the come-back.
So even if they had a
timer, they would
still have to be listening.
Oh, it's about time for
them for them to
get back to me now.
So they're creating work.
This one was also very
interesting.
I had to write things down
because I wasn't sure I was
going to remember what
question I asked.
If I got to "say again," which
could happen, communications
get garbled all the time.
So these things are things
that they're doing.
This is what they're
experiencing in a time delay
that's creating work.
So this is great.
This is solid gold.
This is exactly what
you need to know.
So luckily we had very clever
people who had questionnaires
prepared in order to assess the
coordination difficulty,
which is one of the
things that's
creating this extra work.
So things like tracking tasks
that I've started at the same
time, that's one thing.
But this-- how hard is
it to talk to people?
Is it hard to talk to people
between crew and ground?
So we had some questionnaires
for that.
So what's interesting here is
you're seeing here's how hard
crew felt it was to communicate
with the ground.
And here's how hard ground felt
it was to communicate
with the crew.
So similar, but not identical.
And again, you can see that
the mitigations are making
things better.
So why are the mitigations
making things better?
We had four classes of
thing that we did.
We had the procedure display.
We advance the caution
and warning.
We had chat.
And I had forgotten to mention
that the procedure display
basically is shared between the
vehicle and the ground.
So anything the crew is
doing, it's basically
mirrored on the ground.
So the ground can basically say
oh, that crew person is in
the middle of that procedure,
or was five minutes ago.
So show of hands, who thinks
chat made things better?
Most people think chat
made things better.
Procedure display and
technology, anybody think that
make things better?
Less so than chat.
Advance caution and warning for
the systems failures, that
make things better?
A couple nods.
How about spying on the crew?
I know exactly what step of
the procedure you're on.
Did that make things better?
Probably, all of them
a little bit.
Anybody think that made things
harder in any way?
Maybe.
A couple of thoughtful
looks, nobody willing
to raise their hand.
Aah, raise your hand.
OK.
So once again, the comments
are gold.
So this is great.
Ground says, WebPD made it
really easy to follow along,
even with the time delay.
So I don't even need
to call up.
I don't need to ask what
procedure step you're on.
It just tells me what procedure
step you're on.
So today, you'll even hear
flight controllers calling up
to the crew, saying what
procedure step are you in?
How far did you get
on that step?
Are you done?
I'm seeing this.
Where am I?
No more.
No more need for that.
But look at this.
This one here is very
interesting too.
Now, flight controllers have
to watch the web procedure
display and listen
to the audio.
So they now have more
things to watch.
So some of what was being made
better is also being made a
tiny bit worse.
So that was interesting.
We didn't quite expect that.
That was good.
So the advance caution and
warning, this one is a pretty
interesting one because several
people said that the
failures that we had were fairly
straightforward and
simple, given the simplicity
of the vehicle.
But in a real vehicle where
you've got two, three, four,
five failures deep, something
like this could really shine.
But even here, even in these
simple cases, people said,
gosh, I knew exactly
what to do.
I worked these procedures.
Ground told me what to do.
But I was done already.
So this was pretty much a win.
So that was good.
All right.
So last question, which
is good because
we're almost done.
So even without something like
chat to basically make it
possible for people to talk
less, do you think people
would talk more or less with
increased time delay?
Anybody think more talking with
Less talking with
increased delay?
Anybody think it's
about the same?
No idea.
And then obviously, we would
expect them to talk less.
But let's see what
the numbers say.
Well, surprise, surprise, time
delay didn't seem to impact
how much people talked.
They talked about the same.
So that was a surprise.
So what we're seeing here is
total talk time as measured by
basically clicking on
and clicking off of
the voice loop mics.
So if you count the total number
of seconds, what you're
seeing is that in both cases,
both for the mitigation case
and for the baseline,
people were talking
roughly the same amount.
So that was interesting.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: About the technology,
when there's no
delay, do you still have to hold
duplex, hold the duplex
and talk at the same time?
Or if there's no delay, do
you still push Talk?
JEREMY FRANK: There
is full duplex.
And actually one of the things
that you sometimes find is
people are stomping
on each other.
So I'm trying to talk.
But I've mistimed when
your voice is coming.
So I'm basically stepping
on you.
And that was something that some
other people are taking
our data and analyzing, trying
to understand how did that
sort of come into play.
But yeah, so you could have--
I don't know exactly.
I don't remember how many
channels we had.
And our Kennedy Space Center
participants actually managed
all the coms for us.
And I'm not sure exactly
how they did it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It seems to me that
voice is just completely wrong
for this type of-- when delay
than a few seconds, it's just
not reasonable to--
I mean voice is great when it's
instantaneous or almost
instantaneous because then you
can have a conversation.
But when can't have a
conservation, what you said,
chat is basically email.
Or back in the old days,
you sent a letter.
Never started talking and then
have someone relay your voice
in the same thing.
JEREMY FRANK: That's a
really good point.
Except that a huge amount of
information is conveyed in
voice, even if it's delayed,
and so voice
timbre, choice of wording.
And one of the things that other
people are doing, which
I'll get to in a little bit,
well, voice, email, sure.
You could do that.
But other things that people
started to ask was what was
chat used for as opposed
to voice?
When people had freedom
of choice, what did
they choose to do?
And it turned out that chat
was pretty good for
quantitative data
like numbers.
Voice was good for
non-numbers.
So there are other kinds of
interesting modality questions
that I think don't totally
preclude using voice.
AUDIENCE: But I mean if you
managed voice like email in
the sense that its
all recorded.
You can always go back.
You can always relisten.
And then basically when the
length of is by an order of
magnitude or even sorter than
the delay, it makes sense to
construct a message
and send it.
I mean you can optimize and
start to sending the message
before its finished.
But on management, you don't
start playing the message
until you're ready
to listen to it.
JEREMY FRANK: That's true too.
But as you'll see from some of
the chat context question and
answers, why do people like
chat, there's some other
advantages that we're not quite
there on for voice.
But you're absolutely right.
But this is all about how do
you think differently about
what people do and
how they do it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This might
be your next slide.
I mean did you learn anything
from this set of exercises
that you immediately
wanted to put into
practice with the ISS?
JEREMY FRANK: There were a
number of things that people
wanted to at least
consider trying.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it
seems like a huge win.
JEREMY FRANK: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --lowered orbit.
JEREMY FRANK: So chat's
one of them.
Chat had been something
people wanted to do
for a little while.
The sharing of data with the
WebPD is another one that
people were very excited
about using.
There are some barriers to
putting things on ISS that
make it harder.
So this result that we found
here where basically the time
delay didn't influence
how much talking,
that was a real surprise.
Because we all sort of expected
that it would be different.
But what is very striking and
quite obvious, in mitigation,
people talked something
like 20% to 33% less.
Or to put it more accurately,
80% of the time that people
spend talking, they
spent a lot less.
So the question is why?
Was it all chat or was there
something else going on?
And so we did a-- whoops.
We did a badly constructed
slide, which I failed to QA
before the talk.
Oh, well.
So had something else
had to go wrong.
So what we can do is
we could take a
look at the chat messages.
We could pretend, unlike me,
that a chat message would have
been spoken by either a crew
person or a member of the
flight control team at roughly
two words per second.
And then we can say, if you add
that to the time people
actually spent talking,
what do you get?
And what you see is that you
still get reductions in the
amount of time between baseline
and communication.
So something else in that set
of tools, which we could not
pinpoint, is also contributing
to a reduction in how much
time people are talking.
Some of it's chat.
Some of it's something else.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] procedure
display [INAUDIBLE]?
JEREMY FRANK: Probably.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
I didn't quite understand the
complaint that a procedure
display increased monitoring
[INAUDIBLE]?
It was a few slides back.
Because I would expect that if
they have a display they'd
have to answer it some other
way, whether keeping in their
head or writing it down on a
piece of paper, what step the
remote astronaut was on.
JEREMY FRANK: So this I think
gets down into the intricacies
of when the crew needs to tell
someone, I'm in the middle of
this procedure, I'm on this step
and I have an issue, how
is that done?
Or if the ground wants to know
where someone is and they
can't otherwise find out, what
other displays are they
looking at?
And we didn't have the analysis
and we didn't have
quite the amount of information
to get down to
that level of detail.
AUDIENCE: It seems to me then
if some of the time is spent
checking, asking the astronaut
what step are you on?
Oh, I'm on this step.
Can you repeat?
And if you had a procedural
display, then wouldn't some of
that talk be eliminated by
just referring to the
procedural display.
And it might explain
some of the--
JEREMY FRANK: Absolutely.
But the fact that it's a
nuanced story is the
interesting thing.
It wasn't a knock it
out of the park.
There were no issues
with this.
It was all very natural.
Flight controllers were saying,
I've got a piece of
information I didn't
have before.
I felt like I was doing things
that were contributing to my
workload that I didn't do.
So when we talked to them more
about this, it was less a
matter of this is a problem
with the technology.
It's an awareness of something
we would need to
train people to do.
How is it that you shift your
attention focus from your
monitor displays to your
procedure display, if you had
such a thing?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But I assume you also have to
think of the content of the
discussion.
I think this is something
[INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY FRANK: So some other
people are analyzing the
content a little more to try
and understand and sort of
come up with, if you like, sort
of a formal model of what
people were and weren't
saying.
AUDIENCE: I mean obviously
mission control could be more
easily manned by adding more
mission controllers.
They're significantly
cheaper than the
technical crew on the shift.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY FRANK: Pardon.
AUDIENCE: We hope you get
paid better [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY FRANK: Well, so full
disclosure, I'm not a control
center person.
I just try and give them stuff
that they can use.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY FRANK: And
it's very true.
But the pressure has been to
try and understand what you
must do in order to control.
Can you do it with
fewer people?
Do you really need people
there 24 by 7?
And the answer is it's not
entirely clear if we can.
But the costs of a control
center are very high, data,
voice, the building,
all the com.
Communication itself
is very expensive.
If you look at how much it costs
to maintain deep space
network communications to all of
this remote places, it's a
lot of money.
So controlling the cost of the
control center is still an
important thing to consider
how to do.
All right.
So let's see.
So once again, we got this
sort of nuanced story.
So chat removed the need
to do a lot of things.
You could roll back
and read the chat.
So if you had good voice to
text, well that would be a
good justification for saying,
well, you just speak into the
mic and send an email.
But we don't have good
voice to text yet.
But again, there's now this
other piece of information.
Some of this is just they're not
accustomed to monitoring
these pieces of information,
which I think is to
overcomeable compared to the
obvious benefits of it.
But it's all little
new for them.
So they're still coming
to terms with it.
OK.
I'm almost done.
So I didn't fully understand at
the time that we did this,
about a year ago, a year and a
half ago, that if you look at
some of these things that we're
employing in order to
mitigate a time delay, it's
this mix of old and new or
it's this mix of sort of high
end NASA stuff plus things
that really we're using all the
time and every day now.
And there are other people who
are much more sophisticated
about how communication
takes place.
But deep space missions are
going to be managed in an era
of asynchronous communication in
a way that today's missions
really are not.
And thinking about that and
coming to terms with it, it's
not a big surprise.
Mars missions are managed
like this all the time.
Every single Mars mission
that we conduct is
managed this way.
Missions to places like Mercury,
Mercury Messenger
being the prime example,
they're
managed this way today.
So the human space flight world
is going to ultimately
learn how to make use
of these things.
It's just a matter of time.
And if that's the place where
we're going to send people,
then I think we have a pretty
good idea of how to at least
get started.
So I want to linger on this
slide filled with names
because this was a giant,
cross-NASA achievement that we
actually managed to pull off,
ridiculously in about a year.
I still don't quite know
how we did it.
But props to every single
person on this list.
Everybody worked really,
really hard
to accomplish this.
It was absolutely fantastic, a
wonderful group of people.
I was very privileged
to work with them.
And it was great and I'm done.
So thank you very much.